now there's uh two years left of my co
of my son being in college and one more
semester of my daughter in graduate
school and with my ex I had it set up so
that I paid half like one full year was
mine the other full year was hers but
now she's saying that she doesn't have
the money or she's telling my son that
and so she's trying to force me to use
all of my f29 ST which is totally in my
name and in addition to that my son who
has worked for the past four Summers he
saved about
$10,000 she was trying to force him to
use to drain his entire savings to pay
for this last semester here's the thing
you pretty much know I know and I've
only been talking to you for about 80
Seconds that she's not gonna pay it's
not bad if you're like my son's going to
drain his savings he's paying for his
education and that's good if he's
contributing a little bit